hey guys I'm Brent Rose writer and Cool
Hand Luke and today I am super excited
because we're about to make one of my
childhood dreams come true we have more
than 20 gallons of liquid nitrogen and
we're going to super freeze some things
that as far as we know have never been
super frozen before and then we're going
to smash the living hell out of them and
see what happens it's pure science at
its best we're gonna do it all in super
so today we're mostly going to be
working with liquid nitrogen the air you
breathe is 78% nitrogen gas but when
that stuff gets down to negative 320
degrees Fahrenheit it goes liquid and it
has a lot of really interesting
properties for starters it can make
things really really brittle this is a
lock this is a hammer this is what
happens when you hit a lock with a
hammer
at room temperature okay so put a good
dent in it but lock still spins still
definitely locked let's see how it fares
when it's super frozen I call this one
the Bicycle Thief
Oh was almost an incredible disaster are
we okay a year so that worked completely
fractured why does that happen
in a solid object like this the
molecules are packed very tightly
together and it looks like it's
completely solid but in fact there are
some small spaces in it
this gives the molecules some give but
when an object is super frozen it
actually shrinks down and those
molecules essentially become locked so
when it takes an impact it can't flex to
absorb the energy and it shatters in
hopefully spectacular fashion guys you
might want to cross your legs for this
one this is a 15 inch silicone dildo
let's hit it with baseball bat
all right it's going in I just want to
do the tip first real quick
goddamn that was a spectacular
castration if ever I did see one so
how'd I hit the dildo at room
temperature its elasticity would have
taken that impact and spread it out
across those 15 very real inches but
because the molecular structures were
basically frozen in place and it
couldn't spread out the energy from the
impact site
so basically fractured caused a bunch of
other fractures and yeah that was the
end of that hundred-dollar dildo so
we've seen liquid nitrogen can do to
inorganic materials just imagine what it
could do to human flesh let's find out
in this next test
Peter here is going to throw a full 12
ounce cup of liquid nitrogen directly
onto my bare skin we call this test the
cold-shoulder brand you ready
oh okay uh that was actually very
refreshing I'm not gonna lie okay so I'm
not frostbitten or freezer burn why
because of the light and frost effect
essentially when a liquid hits an object
that is much much hotter than it bursts
into a gas at 98.6 degrees my skin is
more than 400 degrees Fahrenheit hotter
than that liquid nitrogen so what
happens is it bursts into a gas and
forms a small vapor barrier that
protects me from the freezing liquid now
if it has been allowed to pool anywhere
it would have frozen me really badly I'd
be on my way to the hospital now retro
actively don't try that at home this is
a baseball normally you can wall up the
hell out of it and it will rebound and
come back to its natural shape but let's
see what happens when it's super frozen
you know that seemed the natural or Roy
Hobbs knocks the cover off the baseball
well I call this one the natural on ice
aka natty ice be ready well it's so cool
didn't smash at all
this is a lot tougher than I thought it
was going to be let's write a
sledgehammer it oh yeah here we go
baseball's are really tough as it turns
out so why isn't this working well a
baseball is really a small plug of cork
wrapped in hundreds of yards of wool
yarn that yarn traps a lot of air which
makes it a really good insulator combine
that with the toughness of the molecular
bonds of the leather casing you've got
one very freeze resistant ball okay so
we've seen what super freezing does to
some tough stuff let's see what it does
with some light delicate things got a
peacock feather and a rose last Dewar
do-or-die I call this one every froze
has its thorn
that's love whoa nothing that's amazing
so the rose obviously shattered into a
million pieces whereas the peacock
feather never lost its flexibility why
because the Rose is mostly water in
those petals whereas the feather is
mostly air so if you ever had any doubt
what great insulation down is here's
some evidence for you this next one is
what gave birth to the idea of this
whole episode I'm so excited I have no
idea if it's going to work or not I call
this one the frozen Gallagher
that was so deeply deeply satisfying
been dreaming of doing that ever since I
watched Gallagher do it with normal
fresh watermelon when I was a kid it
wasn't totally frozen all the way
through there's still like a little bit
of dare I so what did we learn here
today well when you super freeze
something molecules that normally have
some room to slide around become more or
less locked when that happens things
become more brittle and when you smash
the hell out of them things become more
awesome and if you shoot them with a
high speed camera things become awesome
or still it's basically just excessive
loads of Awesome but what do you think
are there items you'd like to see us do
next time let us know in the comments
below subscribe if you haven't already
with all that being said there's really
only one thing left to do Thank You
Cleveland goodnight